hey guys this episode of congratulations
is brought to you by the cash app it's
the simplest way to instantly send money
to friends it's also the number one app
in finance but it didn't get their own
payments alone these days
cash up is changing how people interact
with their money it's adding features
you can only get from a bank and more
than a few that you can't like the cash
card boosts and Bitcoin download the
cash app for free on the App Store or
Google Play market 3 where are all the
babies are they all are they all here
anyway yeah you are all here or some of
you well you're all here if you're
listening that's how it goes I could be
like hey you're listening now and you're
listening because if you didn't if
you're not you didn't hear it right but
I am I'm super back man and I was on the
road I was on I did a show in Reno which
what the [ __ ] is it and then I did a
show in Las Vegas at the Mirage both
shows were awesome dude the Reno show
was awesome and the Las Vegas show was
awesome
Reno is uh you know I don't know it's
funny how they like it it's like it's
like a I don't even want to say a mini
Vegas cuz it's not it's like they have
hotel they have a casinos but they're so
spread apart from each other it's also
probably they're probably just as far
from each other as they are in Las Vegas
it's just Las Vegas there's more [ __ ] to
do in between them but like you're in
one casino and you look out the window
of the hotel and you're like all the
other casino looks like it's [ __ ] in
California in in California yeah casinos
in Nevada I don't know I didn't know
where we know was but I was in Reno the
great show is about I think twenty four
hundred people there at the show and
then
in Vegas it was sold out however big
that one is
at the Mirage but yeah the I don't know
I'm like I'm like you know you go in you
go in waves you know as a performer
you're like oh yeah I'm really in love
with stand-up and in love with my act
and I got my new [ __ ] and that's awesome
and then you and and touring is cool
going to different cities and then every
now and then it's just you're like oh
man you know you're still you're in love
with stand-up but it's like all you're
tired I'm tired of my material or I'm
tired of touring I want to be home so
I'm [ __ ] but a pop I love in it right
now like I'm having so much fun man I'm
just out there I'm given the [ __ ]
babies what they want but more
importantly I'm doing what I want
because that's what the most important
thing in life is that's the most
important thing in life when Tom I was
in therapy and they were like and they
were like well why don't you want to do
your math homework I was a kid you know
I was like because it sucks dude I'm
never gonna need to use it we're
learning about imaginary numbers that
was it that was when I was out dude
after we started being like after I
heard there were imaginary numbers I
gave I gave up on math I was like done
oh they don't exist [ __ ] see yeah
how many equations am I gonna do in my
life is zero I'm a comedian i'ma cut up
baby cut ups don't do equations so so
anyway I did the Vegas show I had if I
had a crew with me dude it was like the
sad entourage man actually entourage is
the sad entourage that [ __ ] show but
I did I was with three other guys and we
were having fun and I was gonna be in
Las Vegas on the 25th and I can't
remember if I can't remember how it
happened but I got into I'm I'm I'm buds
with the chainsmokers and um and I hit
up Alex or I don't remember if he had a
mirror if it I hit up him but I was like
hey we're gonna be in Las Vegas and he
was like ah when I'm making up this
first part but he we got to the point
were talking about I don't remember how
it started talking but he was like well
we're gonna be there on the 26th and I
was like oh [ __ ] well we're staying
another day as I come out and I was like
all right
and I don't [ __ ] go out you know I
don't really go out my out is my is my
work like when I go out and I do my
shows that's it that's the best version
of me going out as there is everyone's
[ __ ] paying attention to me and
laughing at me and then people are like
you want to go to a bar afterwards and
I'm like no this is the best I'll just
hang out on the patio of the Comedy
Store and talk to the people who are at
my show and [ __ ] you know I mean even
though it's a lot of them are going to
be annoying um but a lot of them are
going to be very cool
you know you get it's a mixture it's
like life dude I took a second for being
him it's like being a anywhere with when
you're anyone some people are annoying
little cool oh so so I was like all
right cool well we were gonna be out
there anyway for an extra day me and my
buddies me and the fellas so why don't
we go out why don't we come to your show
and he was like dude that would be
awesome we'll get it all hooked up
whatever now I didn't know look I'm buds
with these guys I mostly know Alex cuz
we text a lot a bunch but um you know I
met him I can't remember my name in
Australia when I was in Australia cuz
they were in Australia at the same time
and I think we followed in children
Instagram he's like bro were out here
too and I was like ah no [ __ ] we were in
the same we were doing the same press
same show and I was on before them and
then so we kind of hit it off and we
didn't end up hanging out in Australia
but we've been texting back and forth
[ __ ] you know and he was like come
on out so we went out with the buddies
with my buddies met him in their suite
you know and they were having like a
little bit of a get-together and then we
went down to see them perform and Drew
and Alex uh this is the word that comes
to mind went with these felt with these
guys okay genuine you don't meet many
[ __ ] genuine people dude these guys
it was laughable how nice and
accommodating they were and also not
just to me
but to my crew who were all guys by the
way and we they're like yeah come on
down we're gonna play a DI set for a
little bit and then you guys come up in
the [ __ ] spinny thing with the DJ in
the booth the booth spins is that this
[ __ ] place called encore at the Wynn
and it spins because there's 6,000
people there and there's 4,000 on one
side of 2,000 on the other and they DJ
for a little bit it's like then Santa
and then they're light and then it spins
and then the [ __ ] the-the-the the
tour manager Clancy hits everybody's
arms off of the side so it can start
spinning so nobody gets their arm caught
and then it spins it's like and then it
goes around to the rest of the 400
people and it's like don't don't don't
and those wheel are in a pool by the way
so it's either heaven or hell you know
but yeah dude [ __ ] it dude I saw drew up
on the thing up on the spinny thing
dancing around and singing by the way he
woke up an hour before that which was
hilarious it was so funny that was the
funniest part like we were in the suite
and drew came out and he was like
[ __ ] all like tired and [ __ ] and then
cut to an hour later was like don't
doing [ __ ] smash him out Smash Mouth
covers and he was dancing on the thing
and I was like man I'm gonna [ __ ] get
up there I waited till it was cool
because I didn't want to like be like
you know it's their show and I want to
[ __ ] it up like if I was a comedian if
I'm a comedian if someone came on stage
I'd be mad but it's a different type of
thing they were like throwing a party
and [ __ ] so I went up on the thing on
the spinny thing and I got up there and
I started dancing dude and everyone was
like [ __ ] yeah yeah and then a bro I was
like oh I'm gonna fall man I mean I know
alex is like 33 or something but drew he
might be [ __ ] 22 for all I know he's
older than that but he who was like spry
and you know in track pants just [ __ ]
running around on this thing and I was
like oh man I'm 38 I'm gonna fall I'm
gonna fall into some [ __ ] drunk chick
or the guy I did I took this video of a
guy who had this these glasses on
that was that were lit up they would
light up and reached and stuff would
read out in illuminated [ __ ] and and
it's it was said send nudes he was like
this fight look like this Asian banker
but just was so [ __ ] led he was so
just feelin it and he kept pointing at
me and I was like this he want me to
send nudes or what I don't get it but I
put a bunch of it on my Instagram
stories and I put it a bunch of it on my
Instagram so if you want to go check it
out look it up on Instagram but shout
out to the chainsmokers man those guys
throw a party dude
they're gonna be in Vegas for another
two years they signed up for I can't
imagine the [ __ ] money they're making
but that [ __ ]
I love meeting nice [ __ ] people I
also like meeting nice successful people
man dude they live in the life - two
guys who know they're livin who are
living the life and know they're living
the life and just [ __ ] happy about it
you don't see that man sometimes I get
caught up in in in the annoyance of it
all on my [ __ ] this [ __ ] that dude it's
just so [ __ ] annoying and I you know
I love my life but I got a step back and
realize in a way I'm a [ __ ] chain
smoker dude now I'm not out there
creating the vibe they're creating I got
my whole different sort of vibe it's the
cynical but also funny and yet with a
silly vibe kind of vibe and if you're
gonna roll with me you're gonna be
you're gonna be having a good time and
it's gonna be lit but also it's gonna be
silly but also you're gonna keep kind of
the behind the face the [ __ ] cynical
vibe right but when you're a [ __ ]
chain smoker dude you're out there and
you're having the good time life is good
kind of vibe right and that's what I was
doing and we got to [ __ ] remember
that we're all in a way of [ __ ] you
you got to strive to be more of a
chain-smoker man because you got to be
out there and you got to be living life
in that in that sort of way - you can't
just be caught up in here and it's tough
I know it's tough it's tough because
they [ __ ] did it
dude like I said earlier on when I told
him you Joe Rogan said his life is a
masterpiece bro I'm [ __ ] that [ __ ]
stuck with me man you
you got to make sure your life is a
masterpiece and you got to make sure you
know your life is a masterpiece and
these [ __ ] chainsmokers men they know
it
I should have air-dropped that [ __ ]
Asian Bank or some nudes for real but I
wouldn't I didn't know what his thing
was it was probably lit Asian banker lit
Asian banker cuz that's what he looked
like any kept pointing to me and by the
way he was with nobody he was with
nobody he was by himself
changing the illuminated messages on his
sunglasses via bluetooth on his phone
sometimes it said send nudes and
sometimes it said lit he's a lid a gin
banker but anyway dude it was fun oh and
then they were like come on dude we're
done and then they went up and they were
like let's go up to the suite and have a
little bit of an after-party and we went
up and it was like a tame kind of an
after-party which was also my kind of
vibe but guess what they had sliders and
lobster quesadillas ah dude you better
believe I ate a lot of them ah
they were so hot and they stayed hot
dude are we in heaven
lobster quesadillas and sliders and
these sliders didn't even taste like
sliders they tasted like [ __ ] sliders
should taste when you think of ocean
because you know dude when you have a
have you eaten sliders they're [ __ ]
all bad you know if you try a slider
you're like oh this doesn't taste like a
mini burger this tastes like a piece of
[ __ ] mini burger but if you were to
think of a slider before sliders is one
of those good ideas but not good in
actual implant in actual in another word
malfunction it was a they're good in
theory but when you make it you're like
our burgers are burgers cuz they're the
size of burgers and they should be the
size of burgers just because something
smaller I don't get it that's CUDA life
dude you're gonna [ __ ] split some up
make it smaller no no no no no no no no
little little mini pizza pieces [ __ ]
that give me the whole slice
so you make sliders take a [ __ ] hike
but these [ __ ] sliders were how
sliders should [ __ ] taste dude you
ever taste a slider how it should taste
no you haven't you haven't dude I'm
telling you you have it unless you've
been to a chainsmokers afterparty that's
how it is dude and they had lobster
quesadillas oh dude you're not supposed
to put fish with cheese but they did it
and it worked out and you're not
supposed to serve them with [ __ ] mini
burgers and they did it and it worked
out and that's why I dude sliders and
loving his hideous sliders and I wish
the [ __ ] litte Asian banker came up
with us and just had an eye on his
[ __ ] illuminated sunglasses he just
wrote lopsy had it said lobster
quesadillas for sliders depending on
what he was eating you know what I'm
talking about
shout out to these [ __ ] man we
had a good time Brown we had a good time
dude and my friends all had a good time
that's the thing mm-my France we had a
good time and it was good to see the
smiles on their faces
oh dude what was so funny my opener was
there Mike so lucky the guy's got the
life he opens for me does sold-out
crowds has no business doing it yeah I'm
talking about
lucky dog you know anyway dude this guy
[ __ ] we left so oh dude
first of all he was so drunk which you
have to get so drunk if you're with them
if you're doesn't have to get so drunk
you get so drunk that night now he
doesn't get so drunk all the time he
does not have a problem he was just
keeping it lit my babies okay so he had
a good time um and so first me and
another buddy went up to the [ __ ]
circle spinny DJ booth thing okay now
then we got my brother up okay I had to
get my brother up I had two other
friends that were not in the DJ booth
one of them was my other buddy and the
other one was Mike my opener so we're up
in the circle DJ but we just got up
there people didn't know they're out
there but I get a text from Mike on the
text chain and he says get us up there
and then next and then the next text plz
plz which is the best okay
then I then I write yeah okay gonna the
guy says if it's too heavy it won't spin
but gonna try okay next thing I know I
look over my shoulder Mike is there
alright
and he's like we got up here bro no
thanks to you and I was like dude chill
okay
I'll fire you I will fire you and get
you kicked out of this spinny thing
alright then we're up there and Mike
just keeps tossing shots back because
people keep tossing shots to him and
that's what happens when you're up there
in the spinny booth with the
chainsmokers okay and so he says let us
up please and I wrote oh this is nice I
wrote hahahahaha what a [ __ ] okay
then he writes please again and
anyway so so now we're up there and
we're all up there and he's getting so
now the spinny thing now I look over at
Mike and he is having a great time and
then he's getting too drunk and he's
being annoying he sees I go up on stage
with him bro go up and starts pushing
him like bro don't do that man
let's just stop it and he's like get up
there only get a picture with you like
he's my dad and it's my bar mitzva okay
so I'm like number oh don't don't do
that dude they'll be so annoying if
someone's trying to push someone on
stage on my stage
just chill then they grab me and they're
like come up here and and they took a
picture dude they were like come on take
a pic we took a pic and Mike was taking
too long to take the pic and I swear to
god Drew whispered in my ear no wonder
why every comedian hates this guy
because he was talking about cuz he was
talking about it beforehand he was
joking he was giving him a [ __ ] soft
little [ __ ] pet pet it was so funny
though I left so hard cuz Mike was like
yeah comedians hate me and because he
was saying because he would gets to do
the road with me and then drew goes like
this no wonder why comedians hate this
guy dude I left so hard hey who knew the
chainsmokers are real party goers and
they also [ __ ] have a legit sense of
humor I forgot to tell Mike that that's
so funny so anyway so anyway we were up
there and doing the thing and then we're
up there for a while now something that
I pride myself on dude I go pee once a
night my bladder is the size of Lake
Erie okay I never have to piss I'm
looking we're up there for 45 minutes
now Mike I look over he's at like
there's no corner because it's a circle
but he's on the railing and he's like
kind of hunched over and I was like
what's up and he's like probably gotta
pee and I was like ah well we're up here
there's no bathroom on the [ __ ]
spinny thing the bathroom is so far away
and he's like I gotta pee so bad and I
was like I start laughing every time I
look over he's hunched over
having a good time just miserable you
know tries to fist pump a little bit but
then how hunches over again cuz he has
to be so bad like 20 minutes goes by and
he's like bro oh god I'm gonna piss my
pants and I like dude just go he was
having such a miserable I like just go
I'll get you back up here and he looks
at me and he goes this is the funniest
moment of the whole weekend he looks at
me and goes like this
hunched over he says no way dude
I laughed so [ __ ] hard like he would
rather be up there and be uncomfortable
and not be having fun cuz he has to piss
so bad then be relieved and down not in
the place you're supposed to be
he's a check he's an Instagram check
that's what he was in that moment dude
it was so funny and then I told the road
manager I was like yo dude this guy's
got a piece I dude they're done in five
minutes I was like might hold it for
five and he held her for five and then
got off afterwards they were done and
then pissed like a [ __ ] racehorse
head to piss like a racehorse brain
email or a song of all time so anyway
that was our [ __ ] weekend and guess
what been sick for eight days not going
away whatever dude I tried to work out
like a week a week ago and I had swollen
glands and went through it and then
[ __ ] also went to the went to Reno
and in Las Vegas still had swollen
glands it's all good not really sick but
it's all good yeah it's all good um took
flight out to Phoenix
ah and so we [ __ ] we did we were in
Las Vegas still not better but it's all
good dude I guess it's hard to get
better when you're [ __ ] out keeping
it lit keeping those happy vibes you
know I was keeping it lit dude I was
trying to get better but you know what
more importantly than that I'm trying to
keep it lit I'm trying to keep it little
walk I was trying to get lit okay in
there look he's trying to keep it lit in
there okay
by the way shout-out to you babies so
many you guys are making such funny
videos on Instagram and [ __ ] like that
and I repost some of them and have a
good time but yeah do
up on stage with them by the way it's
funny like I you I when I was up on
stage with them and they put their arms
around me and they were like [ __ ] yeah
if they'll you know [ __ ] an awesome
cuz I giver 6000 people out there and I
was like bro how does anybody in this
position like if they were like you know
afterwards we [ __ ] you have been like
yeah no I get it
fare and I probably would have [ __ ]
them I would have [ __ ] the
chainsmokers dude [ __ ] it
lobster quesadilla I'll turn round
sliders that are actually good uh let's
have our nose our noses facing the same
way
ah I mean for real dude that's why you
see that Rockstar vibe and it's like I'm
a comedian and I you know it's like you
know I I get that like I guess I'm
comedians have groupies and [ __ ] but
when you're a rock star
[Music]
when you're a [ __ ] rock star or even
better you do EDM music you know I get
it if you're a bad smelling [ __ ]
that's like portly but dude these guys
are fit they're in shape they smell good
come on man
so funny dude I know they listen to the
part guys I hope they listen this
episode but anyway dude what a good time
that's the thing I you know what I've
realized is that that's how you have sex
with a chick I don't ever really think
about how to do it I just kind of either
do it or don't do it but like I don't
think about how like get-getting I'm
feeling comfortable in [ __ ] that's how
you do it
I was feeling comfortable than a
[ __ ] dude you know and you know
what the most comfortable thing is
cuddling see that's what and that leads
to sexy that's the thing when you're
that comfortable the next step is
cuddling my babies you get somebody
liquor good music hanging out laughing
good times
smiles lobster quesadillas and sliders
next next stop cuddling all aboard the
train to cuddles town screw room stay on
the stay on the train after cuddles town
if you're headed to comes Ville head
into blastin zone
weed about to blast up in this [ __ ] huh
Oh mert headed to [ __ ] berber town
Murr we're here all up everyone off the
plane it's the last stop you step off
the plane he's gone
damn damn damn damn damn dude they
played a cover song [ __ ] some body
wants Tommy no words about that [ __ ]
smash mouth dude have you ever seen this
match mouth video a say 90s dude dude
first of all who didn't be more 90s okay
goatee check sunglasses that are more
square than they are around check
big-ass [ __ ] whatever [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
pants check [ __ ] spiked tips check
walking on the sidewalk next to people
playing on a lawn check do nothing more
90s than a guy walking across walking
down a sidewalk W he's got our net
sunglasses dude does he have the [ __ ]
what do you call it what do you call
that piercing in the lip yep check it oh
my got a jacket on when it's way too hot
is so 90s walking across a lawn on a
sidewalk the funniest [ __ ] one of the
funniest videos on the internet though
is when is when he jumps on the car and
they do this and you don't stop coming
and you don't stop coming and you don't
stop coming in you down stop coming have
you ever seen that video you saw right I
said it to you dude it's so funny the
guy from smashed out jumps some [ __ ]
put it on he made the whole song say I'm
gonna actually just play it here oh it's
so [ __ ] funny dude do what all-stars
but they don't stop coming pitch
corrected you know okay get a better but
you don't I mean get a better title it's
like a [ __ ] Japanese guy did this
okay definitely okay all-star but they
don't stop coming pitch corrected this
is the most [ __ ] this is the most
Japanese thing to call it but dude it's
so funny too because this is one of the
funniest [ __ ] things without it
making any sense
okay so the song starts vans on of
course baggy pants jacket on our net
sunglasses or maybe this made me laugh
hard and it just keeps getting funnier
and funnier and then it just gets
funnier funny this it's all pitch
correct that obviously cuz it says it in
the title
[Music]
and then this part head east keeps
jumping on the [ __ ] thing and then
what my favorite [ __ ] cuz he keeps
jumping he's jumping on the car with his
squat position and keeping over and
keeps jumping on the car in a squat
position and they [ __ ] say my
favorite comment on it is damn this guy
has strong thighs
[Laughter]
call me youtube comments about that
legend has it they still haven't stopped
coming somebody writes it's also a great
exercise
this guy has strong thighs thighs are
the best part young thighs are the best
party um so um so but dude somebody made
that how funny is it that it has 64,000
thumbs up and 626 thumbs down like we
even bothered to but my favorite [ __ ] is
when somebody puts a video like this up
and it goes viral and you don't think
it's gonna go viral and then it does
then the guy will put a comment under it
and it's like yo check out my hair
products I didn't expect this to go
viral but here's my soundcloud you know
I don't give a [ __ ] I forget so I'll
[ __ ] your [ __ ] you fat [ __ ]
yeah did is that a good impression [ __ ]
your [ __ ] you fat [ __ ] suck
head suck ass suck ass yes
alright look you've heard me talk about
me undies a million times but why am I
actually obsessed with them it's as
simple as this when I wake up in the
morning all groggy I can't wait to put
them on because I want to put them on
and I want to feel comfy around my the
region that counts right I pick out
which ones I want to wear every day I'm
like those ones maybe not maybe these
ones all feeling these ones and I put
these on it's a nice way to start the
day okay I'm wearing a fun crazy print I
go out about my day and I keep that to
myself because I don't really show
people my underwear but if I'm feeling
flossy maybe I'm sorry
down a little bit and I'll pick out a
little bit of the cool crazy fun print
right it's really a great it's a great
product it's the best underwear I've
ever had my life they use micro modal
fabric which is a full three times
softer than regular cotton I couldn't
believe how soft these things were to be
brutally honest with you guys
it's the exact fabric you're going to
want down there my undies just launched
a new brand new membership you can level
up your top drawer with new on these
each month members gain access to
exclusive prints that no one else can
get they get special member pricing on
every product biondi's makes and you can
switch styles or skip any month you want
to get your 15% off your first pair free
shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee you go to me on
DS comm slash Congrats that's me Indies
comm / Congrats keepsake hey how many I
got Kosh how many photos are sitting on
your phone how many home runs first day
of school family vacations if you're
like me you probably have a whole bunch
and sometimes you'd love to show them
off on your wall I was just looking at
my photos you know how many I've saved
almost eight thousand and they don't
stop coming and they don't stop coming
eight thousand dude keepsake frames is
the easy way to frame photos from your
phone in seconds whether you're doing
some home decorating or looking for a
thoughtful personal gift it's easy just
download the keepsake frames app upload
a photo and choose a frame I did it I
got a picture of me and my buds jogging
hiking and it's very cool and I'm gonna
hang it up it's in a nice cool wooden
frame that I picked and I like it
keepsake frames are shipped direct from
their studio prices start at just 25
bucks and shipping is always free
decorate your home don't be a loser you
can see a detailed preview of the final
product before you buy do it you want
chicks to come over and be like oh did
you just move in no keepsake frames has
framed hundreds of thousands of
smartphone photos but the one that
matters most is the one you're going to
order create a custom frame print right
now in under 30 seconds right now
they're offering an incredible deal for
our listeners 30% off your first order
when you go to keepsake frames calm /
Congrats download the keepsake frames
app and get 30% off plus free shipping
at keepsake frames
dot-com / Congrats that's keepsake
frames dot-com / Congrats so drunk the
cash app you know the cash app it's the
simplest way to instantly send money to
friends it's also the number one
happened financed my babies the cash
card is free customizable debit card and
you can use at stores or ATMs it's
linked to your cash app balance as if it
were a checking account it even lets you
direct deposit your paycheck you looking
for an alternative to traditional
banking you're not alone millions of
Americans have already started using the
cash card so go do it come on there's
never been a rewards program like boosts
get discounts every single time you
swipe a cash card at coffee shops
Chipotle Shake Shack and beyond just tap
a boost in the app and pay with your
cash card 20 years ago something like
cash app would have been hard to imagine
now it's hard to imagine anything else
of course when you download the cash up
and enter rewards code Congrats five
dollars goes to you and five dollars
goes to time's up Legal Defense Fund
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market and be
like me and be like the tons and
millions of babies that have done this
otherwise it don't stop coming and you
don't stop coming don't stop coming and
you don't stop coming and you don't stop
coming in you don't stop coming don't
stop coming and you don't stop coming
anyway dude checking my email while I'm
doing this being disrespectful
disrespectful check in my email even
though I'm getting paid to talk to you
Brown be disrespect being disrespectful
is the most respectfully me cuz you
being yourself unless you're a
psychopath and what you want to do is
kill paintball bug around our [ __ ] in
the subway don't do it brown one time we
you know that song white lines about
it's about cocaine and we wanted to put
it on the in high school want to play it
at the [ __ ] pep rally and they
wouldn't let us except for at the end of
this song it goes don't do it so
technically it was a song against
cocaine so they let us do it
and guess what said us said we didn't
have anything to do with it just knew it
happened while I was in high school had
nothing to do with it [ __ ] lied to
you guys that's not disrespectful I am I
don't give a [ __ ] I keep it truthful
with you babies though I do if I do a
[ __ ] silly little lie I tell you
afterwards maybe that's the Catholic boy
in me huh huh right i hey dude you know
it's not funny anymore Africa a todo I'm
done with all those memes done with
everyone thinking now it's funny too
about Africa and Toto the Toto song from
Africa or Africa from Toto or whatever
the [ __ ] I don't know what the group is
and what the name is the song that's the
new pineapple on pizza or [ __ ] that's
the new [ __ ] it's just stop with it
instantly stop hey how about instantly
stop it's gonna be exporting man I think
now I was in Reno dude this guy came up
to me and he was like dude krisily i'm a
huge fan what are you doing here you go
in a Burning Man and I said no I said
hey if you're a huge fan you'd know you
know the answer that question now gentle
slam gentle slam nice wait are coming
out just giving you the Grand Slam not
even expecting a big tip just letting
you know how your food's ready right
that's what I was not gonna do as a
matter of fact I should have said well
if you're big fret if he said hey Chris
Lee you're here Reno what are you doing
you're going to Burning Man I should
have said I should have said what I
should have said is if you're a big fan
you would know the answer to that
question now your food's ready
so the should have said now shout out to
[ __ ] the new merch on the store
popping off the grand slam t-shirt check
out the [ __ ] shirt gonna be gone you
know why you know how fast you know
what's gonna sell like hotcakes ironic
is that cuz hotcakes are in all American
slam wear the shirt and give people
whether you want to do some Congress I'm
calm Grand Slams what do you want to
fire them out and do some real Grand
Slams because you have an enemy or if
you just want to tell them quietly that
the food's ready
but these mother
[ __ ] need to know man you get
friendly same people I firmly sound
people all day long
a lot of times when I do it on Twitter
it's a friendly stem but if I'm gonna do
it I bring the heat
what I'm gonna do it the don't stop
coming and they don't stop coming down
stop coming and they don't stop coming
and they don't like Conan the Don stop
coming
don't stop going and it does that up
coming a lot of time I'm wearing Jenko
is hopping up on the hood of a car but a
lot of time I'm just quietly saying hey
buddy just so you know you ready I'm not
even trying to align our noses in the
same direction it's free conscious eat
it when you want men of Italian tongue
around face me you feel ready let me
just put it down
here's your all-american slam you owe me
nine ninety seven or nine sixty seven
however much it is you don't even have
to tip me but if you're a big fan you
know the question the answer the
question on whether or not I'd be go in
a pretty man do you know why I'm not
going to Burning Man because I like all
the outfits that I have I don't need to
make an outfit I don't want to make an
outfit do you know why I'm not a
seamstress hey I'm gonna burn him in you
seamstress hey I'm going to Burning Man
you [ __ ] you worked for Polo Ralph
Lauren no one time I was watching how he
Mandel um doing stand-up like in the 90s
or 80s I was young as [ __ ] and he asked
somebody what they did in the audience
as you on TV he's like what do you do
and he said I'm a purchaser and in my
head I thought some people will call
that shopping and he said that Howie
Mandel said some people will call that
shopping and I was like I'm a comedian
he did that I could do it and now I'm a
[ __ ] comedian so all I'm saying
sometimes the thoughts you have when
you're 9 sitting in your [ __ ] guest
bedroom for your parents house are real
real [ __ ] thoughts now have I been
working on a post-nasal drip the whole
time I've been talking yeah do I have to
hawk a loogie yeah am i doing it no am I
gonna know
even if won't fire hands me a napkin I
won't do it cuz I saw him looking around
but I'm not gonna do it because it's
gross and I don't need that on video for
the rest of my [ __ ] life little drip
down baby anyway I'm having a good time
dude right now with you guys just
chillin you guys are on the phone with
me I know I always say this why don't
always say it but I say it every now and
then you're on the phone with me and
we're just talking in your cubicle yet
home ignoring your wife you're ignoring
your husband you're doing whatever
you're doing but I'm a [ __ ] telling
you right now I'm here I'm a Vegas daddy
and I'm back um block some people on
Instagram and Twitter today
I say hey podcast is coming out
Wednesday somebody tweeted me where the
[ __ ] is the podcast and you check if
it's attached to that tweet because if
it's attached to that tweet I know it's
a joke if it's not I know it's not a
joke
blocked trigger finger block finger
these people don't get it um so anyway
did you see it from
up the [ __ ] thing on Instagram where
he was like John McCain is a great man
whatever
and he died and rest in peace or
whatever he said and [ __ ] it was a
picture of Trump Hey seiga testicle Hey
sigue sigue pista chol my deepest
sympathies and respect go out to the
family of Senator John McCain our hearts
and prayers are with you and Donald
Trump is in the picture
seiga tist achill you know what the
[ __ ] thing is - he didn't put McCain
on there because he knows everybody
[ __ ] knows that he has talked so much
[ __ ] about McCain he kind of can't put a
picture of McCain up there he's like
well everyone knows I hit him I'll just
put a picture myself up there you know
oh man what did he say my heroes don't
my heroes don't get captured or
something
I like heroes who don't get captured
imagine if he didn't for imagine if
imagine Trump in in war with a helmet on
and [ __ ] you just shot wrong wrong
they're like are you gonna die wrong
fake news Trump you got hit you're gonna
die fake news my heroes don't get
captured um anyway dude I went six days
without working out which is unlike me
dude
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] dude
I'll go six days without working how do
I go six days without working out when
I'm this video when I'm this topsy-turvy
when I'm basically an upside down
raindrop dude how the [ __ ] did I go six
days and still keep my seen you eat
Tarzan on vacation figure huh how'd he
do it folks
genetics and the mindset dude he's David
Goggins or
[ __ ] that guy is that it talks about
never stopping dude that guy is that
guys like that guys like that his name
David Goggins dude David Goggins the
[ __ ] ball dude that is just jack city
jack city jack city and he [ __ ] was
like 440 pounds and then I think Rogan
interviewed him once or twice but that
guy's so jacked and he used to be fat as
[ __ ] and he was just like not gonna be
fat anymore and just never stopped
running like he was Forrest Gump and I
followed him on instagram because he did
the silliest do his workouts are like
pushing a tire for a mile a day he'll
just keep flipping a tire over and over
again who came up with that tire [ __ ]
workout by the way some who did that
some fat like farmer that was just like
had to do it once and he was like I was
a good workout and just did it another
day and he was like I bet if I keep
doing this I'll lose weight and now he's
just the Marlboro Man dude he was fat as
[ __ ] he kept on working out and now dude
he never he like he never stops he's
always doing push-ups at like the
airport and [ __ ] and one time the one
time that really made me laugh words he
was like sometimes you just got to face
your fears and he tied his hands behind
his back and jumped into a leg yeah I'm
gonna drown Syd don't promote that Sun
safe but he's still alive cuz he's David
Goggins for my mom did it she died the
guy if
tired of your normal push-up routine
incorporate some of these varieties to
break up the mandatory don't try these
push-ups if you don't already have a
strong base doing the standard push-ups
with their hands on the ground this guy
is [ __ ] taking 10-pound weights
balancing on them and doing push-ups
that's very hard because you can break
your [ __ ] wrists doing it
he's got five pound weights doing it
dude that's so hard I've tried that
before and oh no don't even tell me he's
gonna do oh come on dude he's using
those clips to clip the what do you call
those Kara beer carabiner carabiner
racist Wow that's crazy
god he's a strong fella huh that's cool
I [ __ ] uh I like that [ __ ] as much as
I can't stand the see this is the thing
if your job is to inspire people which
this guy's job is to inspire people cool
I always talk about like those people
who just go to the gym the whole time
and then they're like trying to inspire
like dude get out of here just work out
bro this dude I mean this guy's like he
was a Navy SEAL beyond motivated is his
hashtag that's hilarious
y'all thought you were motivated I'm
beyond motivated Navy SEAL endurance
athlete inspiration just straight up at
the end just you need some inspiration
come to me I like people who try to sell
inspiration like its fruit you need
something like it's on that they're on
the side of the freeway does anybody
need some inspiration here you go
there's a picture with an eagle on it
that'll be 450 ah thank you [ __ ]
weird industry huh
it's a weird industry I got to get
shredded though I got to get shredded I
got to get so shredded I'm gonna get so
shredded that people are gonna be like
look at me in [ __ ] four months I'd be
like
what the [ __ ] happened you know I'm
talking about and I and I'm like hey man
just trying to [ __ ] him just trying to
be [ __ ] super fit just want to jump
far just want to do [ __ ] muscle up
you ever try muscle up or you do the
chin up and then pull your whole body up
you ever tried to do that try to do that
once in a gym first of all well you
don't realize is your scarily high up
you're so high up if you fall you to
hurt yourself I think I was able to do
almost one but it's like you look like
if you're doing it at the gym you look
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] because you're so
high up
I had there's a guy who works at my gym
and he brings on those [ __ ] feet
things that he hooks onto the bars and
puts his feet in it and does upside-down
sit-ups do regular sit-ups or just do it
do a decline sit-up the guy like what
part of your abs are you working so
great so much better that you got to go
upside down like you're [ __ ] like
you're a bat and this guy has a kind of
good body ah get the fat off first if
you want your [ __ ] lower abs to pop
get the fat off first did I need to be
an inspirational guy and that's how I my
[ __ ] is hey get your [ __ ] fat off you
idiots that's me not not the whole guy
that's like you know some days you wake
up you don't want to do it but just make
it legs move in the direction of the gym
anyway you know you just got to get
there and then you got to keep telling
your body make your brain tell your body
to keep doing another one just keep
doing another one when you think you're
spent 100% you aren't you're 75% you got
25% left to go dude [ __ ] that I'm not
being that kind of an inspirational guy
I mean the guy that goes like this
do another one fatso come on you fat
[ __ ] once I stop me eight pizza hey hey
hey the [ __ ] band pieces of [ __ ] is
calling they need another member
do another sit up you fat donut bellied
[ __ ] that's my [ __ ] bro that's the
inspiration I need when I work out what
my Irish buddy mark I go like this I
said come on man he's good oh I'm so
tired I say well guess what you ain't
[ __ ] your mom ain't [ __ ] every
you know ain't [ __ ] cept me cuz I'm
doing it and he goes look at all and
then he does it and then he does it I go
your mama ain't [ __ ] dude that's the
kind of inspiration that we [ __ ] do
here at my [ __ ] at the congradulations
cabin in my cult that's the inspiration
we do we do medium Grand Slams like that
medium Grand Slams and we said you know
what do you want to [ __ ] turn round
you want a doughnut belly dude
get another sit-up going yeah [ __ ]
lazy [ __ ] that's how we do it and we
videotape it and we put it on Instagram
video tape it's old I mean those big-ass
video cameras that dad used to have in
1984 that were just like this like they
were like they like they work for [ __ ]
CBS News and they just want to film you
and your brother and your underwear
making the same poses not realizing
reading a dinosaur book ah yep one time
one time that happened one time I was
reading the dinosaur book with my
brother and we both had our legs in the
same position and we both had our
underwear on and my dad was behind us
trying to take a picture and I knew he
was and I knew it was so I kept my
[ __ ] legs like that and I knew he was
doing it my brother didn't know he was
doing it and my brother moved his legs
and he said wait Matt he didn't it was
back there's a Matt put your legs back
the other way so now it's a false
picture and I knew that and my brother
should have known it too now granted
it's a little bit of a false picture if
I'm keeping my legs like that knowing
that he's back there but still that's
how I was so I'm just keeping it like
that but my brother [ __ ] changed his
legs and made his legs go back after my
dad as it's a false picture I'm not
about that false picture it might look
cool but the [ __ ] in the heart of it
wasn't in there and that's the
difference between me and my brother I'm
more observant I'm more observant dude
when we're reading dinosaur books
dude when Mike had to pee at the
chainsmokers thing and he's and then I
said dude just go pee I'll get you back
and he looked at me and said no way that
was a funniest thing that happened in
2018 for someone to want to be mobile
but be in the area they're supposed to
be then to have to then to be way more
comfortable and relieved than in the
area that isn't the necessary the area
that that's supposed to be which still
by the way is a good area is is so
[ __ ] funny that's so American that's
so what this world is now
days I don't care I'm in pain but I'm in
the place I'm supposed to be dude Wow
well I guess that's about it
I don't know well let's look at some oh
you know what I'm gonna react we got an
elder we have an elder we hadn't had an
elder for a while and we're back in the
elder game here because we need to grow
this cult and we also need to have
elders when we get our loud cabin when
we get our log cabin we need to we need
to delegate jobs and stuff
like massaging and breaking guitars and
burning guitar wood and keeping the
grass at it [ __ ] nice length and you
know mowing whatever the [ __ ] I don't
know and in the cleaning clean the cabin
and massaging here's the guy's name
Mitchell Proust is the new elder not
sure his Twitter Instagram he actually
made the original CUDA quiz app and one
fire has alerted me that we did not give
him an elder position yet which I
thought we did but Mitchell if you're
listening or if somebody knows his
handle can you tweet him and tell him or
reach out if he's if you're listening
because we need to get you that elder
pin man you made that great game to let
us know if it's probably on my Instagram
somewhere no he looked he looked you
didn't find it one fire bet I'll find it
later do we have questions
my tourists come in and you should come
Ottawa Ontario London Ontario Buffalo
Burlington Vermont a bunch of different
[ __ ] places that's funny dude
Raquelle a at Rick Ella 11 speaking of
scary stuff when we were kids is it just
me or was the 60 minutes clock scariest
[ __ ] I go on a [ __ ]
out on a limb here and say he got issues
you probably deep you probably have
deeper issues because that's not scary
maybe you were worried that you were
doing something wrong now look I'm not
gonna - I'm I'm a therapist right here
but maybe you were doing something wrong
and you knew time was about to be up but
yeah it was kind of loud and it was
close to right I'd venture to say it
wasn't not it was not scary but it
wasn't not scary do you know what I mean
for a kid also when we were kids she
said but depends on what you mean 4 or
16 but yeah that's funny if if you could
be cast in one sitcom past or present
which one would you choose well see
that's an interesting question
scons Eastsider change it oh and your
handle is at smooth criminal' change it
change it um will you hide you from the
law dude that's an integration because
every sitcom I would want to be in it
was probably a good sitcom and I
wouldn't want to change it and [ __ ] it
up because I like it so why change why
why fix something that's [ __ ] broke
you know why fixes if it ain't broke
don't fix it I mean I think that's a
saying not why fix something that's
broken Oh sense and that's what I set up
first
um okay now here's a good one camden
Boardman now change it that's your name
even change it Camden Boardman whoever
your parents are shouldn't a name to
Camden if your last name was Boardman
because that's weird
your name should be suborning sue boring
so do you go first of all so foreign
this question do you pistachio do you
pistachios this Russian spy with or
without the shell do you pistachios with
or without the shell do you I'm sure you
left out the word eat which is weird
do you eat pistachios with a nut shell
hey man what do you mean first of all if
you eat the shell you're going to bloody
up your anus one time I ate sunflower
seeds I kept eatin all of them with the
[ __ ] shell I would need to see it
when I was a kid and when I went to the
bathroom it felt like someone was
putting a porcupine I'm about home so
that's all good but if you eat the shell
which I don't think you're talking about
eating the shell I think you mean do I
purchase them with or without the I
don't know because he didn't put enough
words in the goddamn tweet that's why
cuz you Russian spy
so Camden Boardman obviously Russian spy
because that was the name you picked
Camden Boardman that's like one of those
[ __ ] remember that Japanese video
games that used to like generate the
American names and it would be like
flips pale Minh would be a name and
they'd be like Jim D Fodor Jim D Fodor
and flips pale Minh and you're like dude
just look up American names so yeah III
don't I don't know I would I always want
to get the things without the shell my
whole thing is when you're eating the
food I want everyone else to do the work
for you just give me the stuff I put in
my mouth
that's what when you go to like Benihana
or like some of those [ __ ] people
that were they cook in front of your you
get to fry the meat go [ __ ] yourself
bring it out when it's ready I'll
consume it you know I'm not threading
the pants together and then putting them
on I'm just buying the pants and putting
them on will the lost episode of podcast
ever be released to us babies Jeff
hackles let's talk about the first one
ever I doubt it it wasn't good I don't
even like the first few episodes as it
is I might take him down just cuz you
ask that [ __ ] question how about that
dude I get ruthless on you daddy gets
ruthless he's got to get ruthless
sometimes otherwise he's just like the
fun guy can't be the fun guy all the
time
thoughts on karaoke Nathan Vandervoort
um
thoughts on karaoke I mean I don't know
dude if you're bad at you know what my
thoughts on are on karaoke are never
pick a rap song you think you're the
funny guy cuz you're gonna sing get
jiggy with it but you're not rapping a
good rap song singing horribly is funny
rapping horribly is the most annoying
thing in the [ __ ] world
you're not funny because you picked
getting jiggy with it and you and it's
just so ever they get to the middle of
the first verse
and they're just like so tired and out
of breath and they're just like you want
to borrow with the best who's the best
in ability press instead of a best
important service haha getting jiggy
with it all in ha ha and you're just and
they're just so tired with a blue
button-down and [ __ ] you know khaki
pants and you're like oh this is
horrible dude anyway that's about it or
what okay cool
we're gonna wrap this the [ __ ] up dude
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market into a
rewards code Congrats five give get $5
and give $5 two times up
we love you guys thanks merch available
we got that Grand Slam tea and you can
support the podcast by getting all the
other teas follow the leader tour on
sale now at crystally accom youtube
videos usually come out a day or two
later and that's it rate and review the
show it really helps video episodes that
my new special on on Netflix will be
coming out I think in January not sure
yet but you guys Rock and thank you very
much you know what remember
I think we're gonna call this episode
lit Asian businessman or whatever the
[ __ ] it was
keep it real my baby
[Music]